being curious about everything not only
makes you more creative it enriches your
life how then do we integrate a sense of
curiosity into our lives one method is
to seek out what I call side quests in
video games like Zelda there are dozens
of side quests waiting to be pursued
these side quests don't affect the main
story of the game but are driven by the
Curiosity of the player what happens if
I enter this cave or try to get to the
highest point in this area or swim to
the bottom of this Lake many of the
game's best Secrets may be hidden in
caves and forests and Villages that a
player following the basic story line
wouldn't otherwise come across I often
think of my life as containing a series
of side quests every day as I sit down
to work I look at my calendar and to-do
list and I ask myself what's today's
side quest going to be this question
helps me shift my mindset from the
obvious tasks that lie ahead to the
potential alternative Avenues they might
take me down it might prompt me to leave
my office and spend a few hours working
in a local coffee shop or it might
encourage me to explore new software
that I could use to solve the problem
I'm working on by adding a side quest to
your day you create space for curiosity
exploration and playfulness and could
discover something amazing and totally
unexpected along the
way